Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, Barry Meier, who is the former Pulitzer
Prize winning New York Times reporter and
author of the book Spooked the Secret Rise
of Private Spies.
Barry, it's so great to have you on today.
Speaker 5: Thanks, David.
Thanks so much for inviting me on.
Speaker 1: So to start with, when we talk
about private spies, we're not talking about
a private investigator because you suspect
your spouse might be cheating on you.
We're really talking here about high level
intelligence work that often relates to foreign
policy, domestic policy, et cetera.
Give us like an overview of this industry
and kind of how it developed.
Speaker 5: Sure.
It really got its start back in the late 1970s
with a gentleman by the name of Jules Kroll,
who created a company called Kroll Associates.
And at that time, the public image of the
of, you know, the private investigator was,
as you mentioned, you know, the guy in a raincoat
who, like, hangs around hotels trying to catch
cheating spouses.
Kroll realized that there was a huge marketplace
for investigative services, particularly from
corporations, because this was a period of
time where there were a lot of corporate takeovers
and shareholder battles.
So he formed what was essentially the investigative
equivalent of a law firm.
You know, these guys dressed well, they looked
good.
He hired not only FBI agents and former prosecutors,
but really smart college graduates who were
interested in investigations and thus began
this industry that describes itself as, you
know, corporate investigators or corporate
intelligence.
But basically, they are skilled investigators
who were hired by law firms, Hollywood moguls,
political parties, you name it, to go out
and dig up information and often dirt on their
clients adversaries.
Speaker 1: And this can include I mean, I'm
reading Lawrence Wright's going clear right
now.
The Church of Scientology employs individuals
like this regularly.
We could talk about the so-called Trump dossier
and whether that would fit the bill is the
type of product that that would kind of be
produced by this.
What are some of the maybe less obvious functions
of such private spies?
Speaker 5: Yeah, so it could be anything from,
you know, what we think of as legitimate use
of investigators, you know, finding missing
people.
It could be digging up material for lawsuits
and locating witnesses for lawsuits.
But the range is huge.
As you mentioned, groups like Scientology,
which are under public scrutiny, will hire
investigators to dig up information or even
try to intimidate their adversaries or critics.
I mean, when I was first working for the top
back when I was working for the Times investigating
Purdue Pharma, they hired Crowell to investigate
people who were suing the company.
And also looked at me not long ago when Patrick
Reed and Keith was writing his book about
the cyclers, he found investigators sitting
outside his house.
Then you had cases where Hollywood has, you
know, made use of private investigators all
the time to intimidate people.
There was a famous case of Anthony Pellicano
who broke into the car of a Los Angeles Times
reporter who was looking into him.
So, I mean, the gamut is huge.
What kind of unites this industry?
I would say is the willingness of these individuals,
these investigators, private spies, whatever
you want to call them, to use any means necessary
to gather information about their targets.
Speaker 1: So that and that gets me to maybe,
you know, we'll talk about in a moment, maybe
some ways in which there's sort of an upside
here to private spies.
But it seems one of the concerns would be
there might be things corporations want done
or governments want done or whoever that they
would be worried about being caught doing.
And the private investigator provides at least
plausible deniability.
Is that, in fact, the case?
Is that what
Speaker 5: exactly?
You know, it's you know, basically it's private.
Investigators have been described as the gloves
that lawyers put on when they don't want to
get their hands dirty.
And sort of that's that's the concept here.
I mean, they will undertake.
Things that, you know, lawyers will claim
they never ordered and are shocked to learn
when it comes out, they they, in fact, signed
off on it.
Perfect example being David Boys's firm, as
you know, David Boies is probably one of the
best known lawyers in the United States.
He's most famous for the Gore Bush recount,
working for the Democratic Party in that case,
also for bringing the litigation in the Supreme
Court that led to the upholding of same sex
marriage.
You know, a good guy in the view in the eyes
of most people.
In fact, his law firm signed off on a contract
that called for this.
You know, this is really private spying for
Black Cube, who uses kind of very despicable
types of tactics to one spy on women who were
bringing claims of sexual assault against
Harvey Weinstein and also spy on reporters
for The New Yorker and The New York Times
who were investigating Harvey Weinstein's
sexual assault allegations.
Speaker 1: If people are interested in that,
Ronan Farrow's recent book, the title of the
book Escapes Me, but it's by Ronan Farrow.
And it's about the Harvey Weinstein story.
Outlines, outlines that quite a bit to play,
catch and kill.
Yes, exactly.
Now to sort of I don't even know if this is
playing devil's advocate, but to sort of see
it from the other side, there are definitely
circumstances we could imagine where the power
of a government, the American government,
for example, could be brought down against
someone for political reasons or for reasons
that you, me or anybody might say are not
on the up and up.
Is there a case to be made that the ability
to hire so-called private spy, to try to match,
at least in some small way, the government's
ability to bring political charges and and
use their investigative power against an individual
or a corporation could be a good thing.
I mean, I'm thinking out loud here.
Speaker 5: Yes, I mean, you know, let me give
you a perfect example, because there's a lawsuit
playing out right now and the parties to the
lawsuit, neither of them are particularly
attractive.
They're not good guys in Karmon common parlance.
But through a just a bizarre set of circumstances,
the defendant in the case became aware that
his emails had been hacked and that his emails
had been hacked off and dumped on the Internet
on this sort of obscure law website where
lawyers for his adversaries suddenly discovered
them and then used them in litigation against
him.
Right.
Well, after this case was decided, it was
so it was subsequently uncovered by a group
of Internet activists what the likely source
of the hack material was, who had done the
hacking.
And this individual then went out and retained
his own private investigator to dig into this
and is now constructing a case to expose the
hacking that went on against him.
And so, you know, there are many situations
where the use of a private investigator, private
spy, to defend yourself, to go and uncover
wrongdoing that has been taking place against
you by a government or by an individual actor,
private actor is more than justified.
Speaker 1: If you want to think about the
way that journalists, as well as the media
and consumers of media should think about
information that comes from private spies.
I mean, there's sort of protocol for how do
you handle a politician when you're talking
to them for a story you might be writing.
How do you deal with an anonymous source?
How do you deal with a sort of civilian nonpublic
person in order to provide them certain protections
in terms of both the individuals and the information
that comes from them?
How should journalists, reporters and interviewers
be thinking about what comes from private
spies?
Speaker 5: Well, I think this is you know,
this is a real motivation for me when I wrote
the book and it was there was a certain epiphany
for me when I wrote the book, because I deal
a lot with the Steele dossier, the the opposition
research that was done against Donald Steele
by this private investigative firm that hired
an ex
Speaker 1: I against Donald Trump.
Just to be clear, just so the audience you
met, you have done it.
You said Donald Steele, you met Donald Trump.
Speaker 5: Donald Trump.
Right.
And Christopher Steele, MI6 agent, was hired
to basically gather dirt on Donald Trump in
Russia.
Now, when this was being shopped to media
organizations, it was implicit when it was
being shown around by by an investigative
firm in D.C. that was, in fact, formed by
two former.
Wall Street Journal reporters that they couldn't
identify the involvement of this firm, Fusion
GPS or Christopher Steele in the gathering
of the information, had to come from, you
know, sort of, you know, appear out of the
blue.
It was like, you know, immaculate conception.
And when BuzzFeed published.
This information on the Web and it was embraced
by particularly, you know, opponents of Donald
Trump and sort of became the focus of political
and cultural and media conversation for three
years.
It didn't come out until late in the game
that, in fact, this was a product of these
private operatives who put it together and
no one even knew what sources they were drawing
upon.
And so, you know, the lesson I try to draw
in the book and the sort of issue that comes
out in the book is that, you know, we as journalists
and I consider myself one, is that we really
have to be more transparent with our audience,
with our readers, our viewers, our listeners
about where this information is coming from.
Why should we give people who are paid to
gather what's effectively dirt and use our.
Stories or articles are broadcast as the means
to disseminate that information to the public,
why should we treat them like whistleblowers?
Why should we give them complete and anonymity?
Because it's not fair to the public.
The public is being misled.
And, you know, this dance is going on, this
symbiotic relationship that has gone on between
journalists and private spies for decades.
But there is one lesson we should take away
from the whole, you know, steal Trump dossier
incident is that we really do need to be more
transparent.
Speaker 1: They need to be identified as sources,
whereas the FBI might be a source for something
about an investigation.
We would identify where these informants probably
Speaker 5: from a government source.
Yeah.
You know, you need to one, people have a vested
interest in getting out information.
You don't have to say it's coming from fusion
GPS.
You don't have to say persay.
It's coming from Christopher Steele.
But you damn well sure saying that it was
put together by individuals who had an ax
to grind or were being paid to plant this
information.
Speaker 1: This was a paid research project
by opponents of Donald Trump.
Speaker 5: Absolutely.
Yes, absolutely.
By the Democratic National Committee.
And the money was like laundered through lawyers
for the Democratic National Committee.
And one journalist became aware.
That Fusion GPS and Christopher Steele.
We're involved in it then they had a duty
to go a step further and to scrutinize those
people, right, to scrutinize that firm, to
scrutinize Christopher Steele and say, what
do we know about these people who their client's
been in the past?
And how does that influence our assessment
or analysis of how accurate the claims in
the dossier are
Speaker 1: in the very limited time we have
left?
Is your sense that the dossier is sort of
a mixed bag in the sense that I know I'll
just leave it there?
Like, for example, I spoke to Michael Cohen
last week and he said the thing about him
going to Prague, he's really never been to
Prague.
It wasn't like, well, he was in the airport,
but he didn't clear customs.
And so technically, it was like he just he
doesn't know where that came from.
But there were other things in there that
either by coincidence or because they were
better researched, were true.
Speaker 5: Yeah, there's no doubt that the
Russian government tried to influence the
2016 election.
There is no doubt that Donald Trump and his
allies, his son, embraced efforts by Russia
to influence the election.
I mean, Russia.
Are you listening?
Right?
I mean, wasn't that his big campaign rap?
So, yeah.
I mean.
There was that Russia was trying to influence,
but that wasn't that binding or that that
assertion was not unique to the Steele dossier.
You know, it wasn't he was not the only person
that became aware of that.
What is troubling is that the specific allegations
in the Steele dossier, one that that Michael
Cohen went to Prague, when, in fact, if Michael
Cohen had lost, Michael Cohen lied about a
lot of things and he got rung up for lying.
Yeah, but if and he would have gotten up rung
up for lying about that and he didn't.
So he wasn't in Prague for that meeting that
that Carter Page, another Trump ally, was
offered like this huge stake in a Russian
energy company.
No evidence that that occurred.
And the most infamous of all, peaty, which
has yet to emerge.
So there is there is a lot there's a lot in
the dossier which either has.
Not proven to be true or been proven not to
be true.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with Barry
Meyer, author of the book Spooked the Secret
Rise of Private Spies.
Barry, such a pleasure having you on.
I really appreciate your time.
Speaker 5: And thank you, David.
I really appreciate your having me on today.